wenn man lavendel nicht schneidet dann
verholzte richtig schnell
beziehungsweise wird unten so kahl uns
einfach nicht mehr so bissig und schön
wie man den eigentlich gerne hätte wenn
man ihnen aber falsch schneidet dann
kann er ziemlich schnell eingehen da
gibt es also einiges zu beachten und
deswegen sage ich euch heute mal wie man
lavendel richtig schneidet
wir sind hier im lavendel mehr vor
unserem büro und ich glaube diese
sträucher wurden ihren lebtag noch nicht
geschnitten ich kann mir aber vorstellen
dass die in vielen gärten ganz ähnlich
aussehen deswegen dachte ich mir das
sind eigentlich ganz gute
anschauungsbeispiel aber sprechen über
erstmal darüber wann man die überhaupt
schneiden sollte jetzt im märz ist ein
richtig guter zeitpunkt dafür weil nicht
mehr so starke fröste von minus 15 grad
oder so zu erwarten sind und die
pflanzen jetzt auch bald wieder
austreiben und deswegen ist das ein
toller zeitpunkt man kann auch im herbst
schneiden dann würde ich aber nur die
abgeblühte blütenstände entfernen und
nicht ins holz wir steigen jetzt ins
holz aber dabei ist es ganz wichtig dass
wir nicht zu tief schneiden wenn man
sich so ein strauch anschaut dann sieht
man dass der hier unten relativ stark
verholzt ist und dann beginnt so ein
bereich wo die blätter wieder rauskommen
also das ist ein eher grüneres holz und
das ist ein eher braune resorts wenn man
darf niemals in das braune holz
schneiden weil die lawine sträucher
sonst richtig schnell eingehen können
also dass immer beachtung
[Musik]
wir kürzen jetzt sowieso die ganze
blütenstände ein die hier noch stehen
aber dann schneiden wir nur ein stück
weit in das grüne holz rein so dass wir
die pflanzen dazu anregen dass sie neu
austreiben und dass sie nicht so kahl
sind sondern richtig schön buschig aber
eben niemals zu tief schneiden es gibt
also zwei große fehler die man beim
lavendel schneiden vermeiden sollte
einmal dass man zu tief schneidet also
niemals ins graue holz schneiden und
dann zum falschen zeitpunkt zu schneiden
man darf zum beispiel nicht im herbst
schneiden weil dann der winter mit dem
ganzen starken frösten vor der tür steht
und die pflanzen dann kaputt fehlen
können oder zumindest die triebspitzen
und natürlich auch nicht zu früh im jahr
also jetzt im märz und april ist ein
richtig guter zeitpunkt um euren
lavendel streich eine neue frisur zu
verpassen und den ein bisschen liebe zu
schenken
es kann natürlich sein dass die
sträucher nach dem schneiden erstmal ein
bisschen carla aussehen als vorher
aber keine sorge es dauert nicht mehr
lange bis ihr wichtig austreiben und
dann richtig schick werden und wenn man
das jedes jahr macht da immer daran
denkt die im frühling einmal zu
schneiden dann werden die auch niemals
so verholzten und so kahl werden unten
wie das jetzt bei diesen alten
sträuchern der fall ist jetzt stehen im
garten aber noch einige andere ganz
wichtige garten aufgaben an und wenn ihr
wissen wollt welche das sind dann schaut
gerne mal da drüben vorbei ansonsten
geht raus und macht die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
samstag um 10 für ein neues video